que vous savez où on est là on est juste
au dessus de clermont ferrand où parc
montjuzet pour ceux qui connaissent ceux
qui connaissent pas bienvenu alors
aujourd'hui on va se parler de quoi
aujourd'hui on est venu se parler de
samsung est venu prendre le pouls la
température voir un petit peu ce que
vous oui vous vous pensiez des nouveaux
produits de samsung à savoir dans les
poches ça c'est le nouveau samsung
galaxy z folle 4 le nom est à rallonge
on a également le nouveau samsung galaxy
z philippe iv avec ses petits frères et
ses petits soeur de l'édition obispo qui
vous expliquer cela soyez assurés on
aura également de la montre on aura une
samsung galaxy watch 5 une voix cinq
pros on aura aussi des belges qui sont à
dans ma poche un peu plus en profondeur
juste là je les avoirs on a les buzz
deux pros qui sont juste la galaxie buzz
de pro l'idée c'est quoi c'est de venir
vous voir vous autres que ceux qui sont
par ici allez demander qu'est ce que
vous en pensez on regarde un peu les
nouvelles fonctionnalités pour vraiment
un retour terrain comme ça c'est simple
c'est clair c'est honnête c'est précis
et on y va tout de suite et surtout
merci à samsung de nous donner la
possibilité de faire cette vidéo qui
aujourd'hui en collaboration avec sa
leçon aux leaders
salah boni a livré nicaise ya des
nouveaux téléphones les nouvelles choses
qui arrivent chez samsung je te montre
et tout ce que tu en penses réaction à
chaud ok ça à temps c'est comment ça se
prend dans quel sens non j'ai pas de là
sans découverte absolu qu'est ce type ce
test on pense à chaud comme ça en termes
de prise en main verte déjà c'est une
dinguerie c'est le flic je crois ça il
est incroyable s'il en plus il est super
j'adore la couleur aussi il y en a
plusieurs ça c'est la couleur la vente
de base et l avant ok tu vas différentes
couleurs également j'ai aussi cette
couleur là ouais ça c'est différent mais
ce qu'en fait c'est une édition spéciale
qui s'appelle bespoke en fait tu peux
venir customiser ça veut dire que tu
mets la couleur que tu veux sur les
différentes faces également ton contours
donc là c'est tout noir avec cette
couleur un peu entre ambroise mais tu
peux l'avoir avec un côté blanc aussi
haut avec un côté un peu différent tu
vois et customisées comme tu veux assez
stylé et c'est quoi ta couleur préférée
toile et quand on a déjà vu ce format ou
pas du tout ça mais je n'aime pas du
tout bon alors ça c'est le nouveau
samsung galaxy z flip 4 le nom est un
petit peu rallonge ouais en fait l'idée
c'est d'avoir un smartphone qui va venir
se replier pour avec un écran qui se
plie et d'avoir un peu les plus petits
qui passent dans la poche femmes l'oeil
dans ta poche et dis moi qu'est ce que
tu penses du format c'est léger ça du
mal un peu à sortir de la poche c'est
vrai que vaut mieux ça qui tombe à
chaque fois oui il allait bien il allait
très bien quand même quand tu trouves
comment je mets un peu les grands
téléphone déjà puis enfin qu'on est dans
la main en fait on se rend même pas
compte qu'ils se plient way du coup
c'est un plus parce que pas certains
pour se dire oui vu qu'ils se plient y
aura un trait alors pas du tout vraiment
j'aime bien vains trouver ces raisons je
vais te donner allez un smartphone comme
ça s'il te laisse regarder l'expérience
déjà on doit leur là sur la coque c'est
pas mal alors ouais je le trouve très
bien ça me change de tous les téléphones
que jusqu'à maintenant c'est plus
moderne après moi c'est vrai que le
petit pluie ne me gêne un peu c'est pas
trop mon truc bon ben là on est parti
vers mon bon vieux vol c'est un pote
mais il sait pas tout je lui ai rien dit
j'ai aussi avoir l'avis de certains
copains je vais te montrer des nouveaux
produits de samsung qui ont été annoncés
mais qui sont pas encore possible dans
le commerce où tu me dis ce que tu en
penses est-ce que tu connais ça n'ont
jamais vu à jamais sa défense j'imagine
non je te laisse ouvrir ce que cette
donne des sensations temps pour se voir
déjà un autre qui spi termes de format
en termes de praticité c'est pas mal ça
a l'air costaud pour un truc pour moi je
le trouve bien ouais mais éthiquement il
est bien et en j'aime bien aussi la
taille qu il est de bonne taille l'écran
est grand et pas trop non plus quoi
c'est pas non plus pas non plus une
tablette quoi je trouve très beau
j'adore effectivement il est un peu
lourd après j'ai déjà samsung dont je
connais un petit peu
c'est comme à la maison quoi ouais non
moi je
j'adore ce mondialement est-ce que tu
connais cette dette c'est le flip
galaxy z fit passer le 4 c'est la preuve
que jamais que je m'aventure alors
retour à chaud expérience qu'est ce que
tu en parles à ce que tu aimes bien non
ça c'est cool on voit la démarcation tôt
mieux mais je pense que c'est un truc on
peut s'habituer ouais mais selon nouveau
désigné après moi je sui team petit
téléphone vraiment mais du coup pour le
coût de cette petite fille ça c'est cool
ça aussi c'est sympa j'aime bien pour le
petit écran le petit écran derrière puis
le même j'imagine en tant que
photographe sont imposés comme ça c'est
exactement le mode trépied à ses
couleurs mais ça c'est vachement bien si
effectivement tu veux te prendre en
photo c'est vous lancez une vidéo tu
mais comme tu veux et tu es vachement
troqué on peut voir leur là aussi latin
écran en fait un écran notification sur
lequel tu as des infos des contacts que
tu peux appeler la musique tu vas voir
ta météo taplin de widgets ton
calendrier plein de trucs que tu peux
avoir ça c'est pratique et ça en plus
parce que tu es là regarde je te montre
si je double cliquer là hop on active la
caméra oui et tu mets la main comme ça
voilà et ça fait une photo on voit ces
pratiques et lorsque je veux te prendre
en photo sans fin qui tombe magie toi tu
peux te voir oui
comme ça tu dois claque photo gj
justement sur internet que on peut le
plier plusieurs fois même très longtemps
plus de deux cent mille fois les
sarthois là donc ça va après c'est vrai
que la pliure elles viennent pas tant
que ça en finale ici mais il est grand
quand même il est très très grand je
sais pas s'il tient justement dans la
poche s'il vient en grand comme ça mais
plus
proche alors si tu prends les grands
smartphones j'ai ça aussi parce que tu
connais cela va essayer l'autre
justement je pense qu'il se met à table
est presque comme ça oui mais je serai
plus entêtés pour plus justement l'autre
que celui là parce que je suis là pour
moi c'est trop gros écran mais c'est
vrai que pour ceux qui sont fans de
cinéma ou quelque chose comme ça pour le
netflix pourquoi ça fait très
intéressant alors je te montre autre
chose ce soir c'est le flip c'est l'idée
d'un smartphone et tu viens réduire
l'encombrement est maintenant temps d un
autre c'est celui là c'est le fold le
fold il est différent parce que tu viens
augmenter la taille de ton écran ça et
j'aime bien parce que du coup le joue
beaucoup sur téléphone
quoi attend d'un écran ici aussi il
s'agit des dieux si tu devais le
comparer à un smartphone tout celui là
qui est quand même un peu plus gros mais
qui par contre vous viens s'ouvrir
lequel tu préfères ci serait partisan
poids de quel produit alors moi je fais
cinéma du coup j'ai bien regardé des
films tout ça donc je dirais lui après
pour ce qui est un peu ce qui pourrait
être un peu chiant un peu galère c'est
la taille dans la poche un peu plus haut
un peu plus grand mais en soit je
préfère est celui-là à suivre d'accord
ou pas tu es plutôt teamfight petit
c'est ça c'est ça ok et toi est ce que
dans la gestion de ton affaire au
quotidien ces choses qui pourraient
intéresser d'avoir un téléphone qui peut
vraiment s'agrandir comme ça qui peut
utilisé avec un stylet avec ses anciens
plus ça fait comme une partie externe
tout ordinateur tu as toujours avec toi
quoi ok tout sur les maîtres et les
traitements de fichiers excel d un petit
peu de word pdf c'est surtout sa cour
soit en général quand même assez
intuitif au moins kg métier de samsung
s'est notamment faciliter son le multi
sans fond d'écran 3d contre c'est vrai
que tu me dises toi ton point de vue qu
est ce que tu préfères entre plutôt team
flip ptin fold le flip
il avait déjà regardé sur le modèle
d'avant d'accord ok je suivais mon frère
là et je trouve qu'il est roux le fait
que ça soit comme une mini tablette
j'adhère pas vraiment mais je préfère je
préfère celle des teams clip même si
c'est vrai que pour regarder des films
alors votre question je te montrerai des
téléphones justement tu démontres dis
moi ce que t'en pense ça c'est la
nouvelle galaxie watch 5 ça c'est un
modèle 40 mm et là tu as l'autre monde
c'est le modèle professionnel qui va
être un peu plus grand qu y avoir une
fermeture différentes comme ça déjà de
base d'un point de vue esthétique et
s'il y en a une qui te plaît si oui
laquelle na waie sur le côté s'est
extrait plus celui-là parce que j'aime
bien justement les les petites bordures
et même le côté pratique de la fermeture
que la basique de ce côté là après je
prenais pas la tv connectée ou patois
ouais ils vont te connecter poursuivre
ton sommeil rythme cardiaque du sport
qui fait du sport ou pas oui c'est des
choses qui t'intéresse oui même pour les
oui je le rythme cardiaque ou même des
exercices de respiration sa bien aimée
je trouve ça vachement intéressant donc
ouais marche course vélo sommeil sommeil
c'est pour moi il est super intéressant
donc l'intention aussi donc là bon ton
poids aux la batte muscles squelettiques
pas 25 kilos de muscles tu as masse
graisseuse 5 kg en imc disait hessel et
ouais
mais franchement ben comme du coup c'est
un peu d'activité physique du coup ces
deux données que j'ai plus ou moins on y
est
ben 10 vraiment on y est vraiment
entraînements ça c'est les nouveaux
galaxy bugs de pro les nouveaux
écouteurs de samsung je te laisse procès
doit s'ouvrir je te laisse la merde dans
les oreilles et on va regarder de
souvenirs ce que tu en penses tu as
chaud là s'éprend de mettre dans tes
oreilles et gpat un peu de musique et
maintenant je te coupe je t'en faire
mais je te mets la réduction bruit en
écoutant la musique essaye de parler de
commenter dire que mon des troubles de
la qualité du son essence est dans ton
cerveau déjà ouais ouais c'est fou je
vous entends plus parler à sa demande
mais je garde ça les gars comment tu
trouves la qualité un son se sert de
bouche pas quoi et là je te dire un truc
c'est l'eau de 360 ah oui là samuel
dirais qu'on est sur scène et la gym est
encore autre chose suivi des mouvements
de tête pour la tête à l'est où la
musique la passe et leïla c'est live à
l'espace c'est un peu chiant je suis
dans les modes que tahiti 1375 cours est
carrément sur saône quoi tu as
l'impression des dons du rail ont fait
avec jean karl en piqué là tu te
retournes dans la grosse caisse que là
c'est vraiment impressionnant j'avais
déjà vu sur le réduction
votre 360
incroyable
le galaxy ses deux filles de quatre et
dispo à partir de 1109 euro et pour la
version wii sports qu'on est à 1209
euros vous avez des prêts qu jusqu'au 25
août 150 euros de bonus reprises en plus
de la côte de veau smartphone le galaxy
z sol 4 est dispo à partir de 1799 euros
le s pen von gerich 49 euros vous
profitez de 200 euros de bonus reprises
en plus de valeur votre smartphone et
galaxy buzz deux profs sont dispo à 229
l'europe et pour toute précommande vous
avez un chargeur duo sans fil offert la
galaxie wall5 et dispos à 299 euros avec
des boys live offert plus 50 euros de
bonus reprise et 30% de remise pour
l'achat d'un folk à trous d'affilée 4 et
la galaxie web 5,3 et dispos à 469 euros
avec des bugs live offert 100 euros de
bonus reprises et 20% de remise pour
l'achat d'un faux 4 août flip quatre
bons et la voilà ça y est ça s'est fait
comme ça vous savez vous avez pu dit
vous avez choisi vous avez dit qu'elle
produit vous intéressait le plus c'était
très chouette jeu très content merci à
5,5 de m'avoir permis de faire une vidéo
très atypique très à part d'avoir votre
tour à vous directement ça c'est
extrêmement chouette alors vous c'est
pas vous derrière votre écran oui toi
quel est le produit qui t'intéresse
quels sont les produits qui vous
intéresse le plus parmi tous ceux qu'on
a regardé ensemble vous marquer juste en
bas ça en commentaires et vous me dites
telle fonctionnalité qu'est ce qui vous
plaît plus moi j'allais m'amuser un peu
et prendre mes écouteurs ma montre bon
smartphone jeu mettra peut nous faire un
peu de relief est allé courir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]